hello everyone and a special welcome to
john stamos who i sincerely hope is
watching this episode of versus because
on today's program it's a cavalcade of
comedic craziness that will pit two
hollywood a-listers into a competition
that will only allow one of them to have
the coveted top bunk oh jesus my heart
is beating so fast if you ain't first
you're last in the world of verses and
stepbrothers will ferrell and john c
reilly are picking up the shovels and
going at it in the front yard once again
no no no need for that come on now
everybody keep your wigs on now in one
corner you have celebrated funnyman will
ferrell he got his start on saturday
night live and since then has played
everyone from an anchorman to a nascar
driver to one half of the greatest
detective team in history
sherlock holmes charmed
in the other corner it's beloved
character actor john c reilly who got
his start on stages in the midwest and
since has played everyone from a new
york gangster to a nascar driver to the
other half of the greatest detective
team in history wonderful yes folks
holmes and watson are the best crime
solvers of all time hey hey even if a
certain movie about them isn't quite as
memorable oh please
how dare you see i work hard here every
time you all think oh mark cause it's so
easy he just has to look pretty while
laughing at talladega nights just
remember i also had to watch holmes and
watson where did i go wrong
or at least research it for 15 seconds i
can't do that to myself it is glorious
i've seen it i'm not gonna watch the
movie what i can happily do is tell you
how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
iconic characters round four range and
then we'll do a wild card round that
could involve wrecked boats wine mixers
or even samurai swords autographed by
american idol judges
i do love these episodes where we get to
chew the fat about movies i don't have
to re-watch because i already have them
committed to memory step brothers might
be the funniest movie of this millennium
but these fellas aren't just comedic
stars and animated film behemoths they
can do drama even a little singing and
dancing and fighting i've been called
the songbird of my generation the easier
question is what can't will ferrell and
john c reilly do we're streaking we're
going up through the quad to the
gymnasium well they both can't win
today's episode of verses but you can
because this show will be chock full of
the best moments funniest lines and drum
set friskiness
of these two great careers thus far
let's get it on the game is a starting
round one box office
sure you've heard of will ferrell and
john c reilly you've probably gone to
see their movies see them on posters and
caught more than a few of their flicks
scrolling through your streaming service
of choice or channel surfing but they're
more than just household names these two
fellows have starred in a ton of
gigantic blockbusters over their storied
careers hey
it isn't star prince some together most
separate and they both show up when we
least expect them
damn right but we all knew we were in
for hilarity with the anchorman films
and we were pretty sure that was john c
reilly voicing the titure character in
wreck-it ralph right i'm sorry i just
you lost me there but both fellas have
somewhat of a surprise or two at the top
of their greatest box office successes
list riley's highest grossing flick to
date is guardians of the galaxy which
hauled in 770 million dollars around the
galaxy and a bunch of a-holes he was in
that about as much as will ferrell was
in his chart topper the lego movie which
did 468 million dollars all told
diabolical as far as their starring
roles we stay in the world of animation
for their premiere dollar counting turns
farrell's megamind did over 300 million
dollars worth of business and rowie's
two ralph looks have done over a billion
around the globe the rest of raleigh's
top 10 buck grossers are primarily
supporting roles in acclaimed films like
chicago gangs of new york and the
aviator while farrell rounds out his top
10 starring in comedic juggernuts like
the daddy's home duo elf and anchorman 2
the legend continues that is in no way a
brag brian now if you assume that will
ferrell has an impressive overall
multiplex resume you'd be right his list
of box office blockbusters makes his
cinematic career comparable to the
football pedigree of his beloved alma
mater the usc trojans i smoked pot with
johnny hopkins good luck lincoln riley
the new football coach there no relation
to john c they spell their names
differently when you add it all up will
ferrell films have totaled 4.3 billion
dollars worth of worldwide cash register
bells making for an average of
107 million dollars per flick that's got
to be more than enough to topple the
character dude john c riley in this
round right just wait till you see what
happens now
well the funny thing about supporting
roles they're usually supporting even
more famous a-wisters thus the movies
themselves could be kind of popular
guilty as charge and rowey's total film
dollar amount out beefs his counterpart
by over a billion dollars well well well
look who's back in the game his global
earnings so far are at 5.6 billion
making for a per movie average of 125
million
holy crap this guy knows how to pick a
winner and deliver a knockout
performance in the process i think i'm
doing okay for a 15 year old with a wife
and a baby but it might not be enough to
fail will pharaoh in this round why well
a billion dollars plus is a sizable
difference but we also have to weigh
starring roles against you showed up for
a few great scenes movies ah statistics
they're so much fun to manipulate sixty
percent of the time it works
every time
that doesn't make sense both gentlemen
have cameoed in numerous films where you
don't expect to see them hey that's will
ferrell and austin powers too oh look
it's john c reilly in kong skull island
but more often than not it's will
ferrell in the weed of a film and john c
reilly amongst the cast of a motion
picture farrell certainly loves the
famous cast around him notable co-stars
over the years have included people like
steve carell
i just burned my tongue paul rudd kevin
hart mark wahlberg i am a peacock you
got to let me fly and amy poehler to
name a few oh and john c reilly but it's
still a well-feral movie that's being
sold i'm kind of a big deal john c
reilly has started many great films too
much a claim but the box office results
can't compare to when it's a feral
vehicle it's true
i don't deserve nice things
it's like the showtime lakers of the
1980s james worthy won a bunch of titles
with them and he earned all those rings
but do they win any of those series
without magic johnson running the late
show i wake up in the morning i piss
excellence i dare say not and yes that's
another southern california sports
reference i used because despite not
having the gaudiest numbers today will
ferrell did the lion's share of his work
as a headliner so he gets the point in
what will probably be a very
controversial round did that go the way
you thought it was going to go
nope
ah this probably means dale won't let me
play his drum set anymore will he ah too
bad will ferrell wins round one and goes
up one nothing i just want you to know i
hate you round two tomato meter slash
audience score
going into today's episode most of you
probably thought will ferrell was the
favorite to win and with good reason but
it's arguable that john c reilly
outplayed him in round one despite the
idiot host and even though he didn't get
the point he proved he's in it to win it
oh i'm gonna walk
hard so a great place to start might be
with critics and audiences how'd they
feel after contributing to that 5.6
billion dollar total amount of multiplex
receipts
i think they're pretty happy with their
purchase john c reilly has a gaggle of
movies all above 90 on the tomato meter
and you know what before i go any
further i just have to mention that both
fellas have a low point of 10
for a film on the tomato meter and
that's not a coincidence because they
both star in the movie the the same one
it's holmes and watson silence
okay moving on riley's doing great at
the top boogie knights tops his resume
here with a 93 percent stan and i earned
him a ton of critical praise some award
nominations and a 92 percent on the
tomato meter and chicago for which he
received an oscar nomination for best
supporting actor currently sits tied
with cedar rapids and the aviator at 86
percent meanwhile will ferrell has made
a ton of crowd-pleasing comedies over
the years but were the critics laughing
sometimes the lego movies at 96 percent
but as far as starring vehicles go elf
is tops at 85 percent the other guys is
at 78
and the anchorman films average out at a
fresh 71
i'm really really good the problem is
he's also got some big swings that
didn't draw any contact with the movie
reviewing contingent you know how to cut
to the core of me like a night at the
roxbury at 11
the house at 20
and semi-pro at 22 which i do agree with
except that poker scene still fall down
hilarious
we're saying nutty things because
they're not true
john c raleigh's tomato meter history is
also marred with the occasional misfire
but they never reached the treacherous
depths of will ferrell's duds the
perfect storm is at 47 percent cirque du
freak the vampire's assistant that was a
real movie and not a dream i had well
that's at 38 as is days of thunder what
that movie isn't fresh at like i don't
know a thousand percent you gotta be
kidding me speaking of racing pharaoh
and riley have another nascar flick
together that is happily fresh talladega
nights the ballot of ricky bobby and his
pal carl naughton is it 71
all right way to go team
shake and bait
and while step brothers tragically isn't
fresh it is my fervent belief that its
rotten number of 55 percent is the
single most important reason that the
book and delightful christmas gift the
rotten movies we love was greenlit in
the first place look at the cover now we
just need a sequel where i can give days
of thunder its justice he rubbed you and
robin's racing he didn't bump you he
didn't nudge you he rubbed you and
robin's son is racing all right enough
fun now it's time for math will ferrell
movies fought hard but only average of
49 on the tomato meter meanwhile john c
reilly despite his vampire movies
maintains a fresh per film average at a
bill and ted approved 69 percent dude
all right look at his go now carl
naughton is poised to slingshot ahead of
his bff ricky bobby but let's first
check the audience score it's a lot
closer
i don't care sure why not
riley's only flick in the 90s here is
guardians of the galaxy at 92 but he has
a nice run of freshness in the 80s with
movies like the hours magnolia and
what's eating gilbert grape he was in
that
cool i guess you could say i've gone
through a rather dramatic transformation
meanwhile will ferrell has some classic
staples like old school representing
well at 86 percent and a more dramatic
turn with stranger than fiction at 85
percent but as led zeppelin would say
the song remains the same farrell gets
closer to fresh but can't quite get over
the finish line with an audience score
per film average of 54 percent riley's
batting average dips but remains fresh
with a 63
okay so we got out of this round with
just one quick holmes and watson
reference
well that makes two and even more to the
point we got us a tied ball game john c
reilly wins his first round of the day
and it's one to one we got a belly full
of white dog crap in me
and now you lay this on me
round three iconic characters if you
start on snl and are known as one of the
greatest cast members in the history of
that show that has included the likes of
eddie murphy chris farley and tina fey
you probably know a thing or two about
creating characters that's been the
journey of will ferrell but john c
reilly is literally known as a
transcendent character actor it all adds
up to a doozy of a round that will break
the current tie and when it comes to
breaking things take a guy named frank
and just add beer i appreciate it but i
told my wife i wouldn't drink tonight
once it hits those lips it's so good and
a human being becomes a tank and
hilarity ensues old school was the film
that cemented farrell's transition from
a funny sketch player into a movie star
and he was just warming up the name ron
burgundy might be even more famous than
the title of his own movie anchorman and
with good reason do you know who i am
he's the perfect embodiment of a dopey
1970s news anchor
what did you say who may not be mean
spirited but his abundant ignorance
leads to moments of misogyny the
fracturing of social mores boy
that escalated quickly and overall
chuckles of plenty i'm in a glass case
of emotion even in films where we didn't
know wilfer was going to show up he
still left us happy he did lord business
was a welcome addition to us former lego
geniuses in the lego movies and another
frank made the perfect cap to the
wedding crasher saga hey ma could we get
some meatloaf did he ever get that
meatloaf we may never know what is she
doing i never know what she's doing john
c rowe has made an art form out of
showing up and making the most out of
his screen time his turn as reed
rothschild and boogie nights showed
glimpses of a career that would go on to
walk the line or better yet walk hard
between comedy and drama well my mother
liked it a whole lot your mother was
wrong his aloof husbandry and flicks
like the hours in chicago makes for a
nice contrast with the grounded
ridiculousness of hank in kong skull
island i'm gonna stab you by the end of
the night
really
just kidding
a less capable actor could have taken
that role and ruined the framework of
the movie but with john c reilly it made
him one of the film's standouts it's a
good group of boys we're all gonna die
together out here you're a good group of
boys to die with i'll tell you that much
he should have come here you know
besides
kong
dewey cox and happy jack morani had very
interesting stories to tell but some of
riley's most notorious characters had
been in films that starred him alongside
his buddy well except for on this show
will ferrell did we just become best
friends yup carl naughton and ricky
bobby make the perfect team until they
don't kyle do you realize the
implications of of your actions right
now what's implication mean that's the
plot on screen but watching the film we
almost need two idiots to bounce between
so we get a momentary break from the
other one or in the case of step
brothers we get two geniuses in
virtually every scene knocking it out of
the stadium can you imagine anyone else
in the roles of farrell's brennan and
riley's dale even if you could who are
they gonna play off of that would make
the magic that our two stars did god
you're gonna make me cry
[Music]
what poem is that from said james joyce
witness their early fights their best
friend's realization their stage browser
the catalina wine mixer
it's their individual talents and
combined chemistry that make this one of
the most rewatchable elixirs in film
comedy history
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
was that a fart but this round is all
about those most iconic of characters
and if dale and brennan are tied and
ricky and carl are a close one-two combo
only one actor is still enjoyed by
families every season of giving the
pumpkin spice lattes turn into
peppermint mochas and buddy the elf
shows up on millions of tvs to bring us
all some christmas cheer looks like a
christmas tree add him into the blender
that also has frank the tank ron
burgundy and chaz michael michaels from
blades of glory and what do you end up
with a truly iconic character who mugatu
would describe as hot right now i'm a
hot little potato right now john c
reilly gives will ferrell all he can
handle in this round but in the end it's
still farrell who takes the point it's
back to a one one-point lead for frank
the tank and it's two to one are you
messing with me right now round four
range
so yeah a nice score for team farrell
but having the most iconic characters
doesn't necessarily mean you display the
most range while playing them i was
gonna say exactly the same thing this
round is going to be another tough
contest between two gents who've
displayed a breath of ability in a
variety of roles over the decades and as
i mentioned before john c reilly has
already been nominated for an oscar but
can will ferrell sneak up and steal this
round and thus win the whole match
it's a definite maybe the first time
that i your fearless host mark noticed
that will ferrell had some dramatic
chops was when he did a little family
comedy called kicking and screaming he
plays a dad soccer coach and while the
movie's certainly a comedy it was very
different than something like old school
or an anchorman this wasn't a silly
character that the filmmakers didn't
bother making three-dimensional this
felt like a real person plus legendary
chicago bears coach mike ditka has a
solid role in the film you're supposed
to back me up and go get me juice boxes
when i tell you now go get me a juice
box in some ways you could make the same
argument for elf while buddy can be just
as ridiculous as frank the tank in some
ways he has a heart that shines through
even in the midst of all his lunacy
comedy isn't just a section at
blockbuster
or it wasn't just a section it blocked
but you see children we have to leave
the house back in the day to go run a
movie i'll tell you about it later the
point is there's lots of sub-genres
within comedy and will ferrell has the
range to master them all wow i actually
appreciate that for every goofy role
like a large eric song or a jackie moon
he can also play more grounded and still
get laughs with turns like harold crick
in stranger than fiction or even with
his recent run as marty markowitz in the
shrink next door but while will ferrell
checks all the comedic boxes one could
hope for john c reilly films can be
found in literally every section in
hollywood video
come on admit it we all cheated on
blockbuster occasionally with the
hollywood folk down the street what is
wrong with you he can do comedy for sure
just check out walk hard the dewey [ __ ]
story but he also wouldn't be out of
place in something like guardians of the
galaxy or the good girl and his comedic
chops and earnest-like ability allow him
to mix genres into one role like with
the promotion the lobster or even the
wreck-it ralph films but for a full
examination of john c rowley's range
just go back to one year 2002 where he
accomplished the nearly impossible
dude was in three of the five best
picture nominees at the academy awards
gangs of new york the hours in chicago
were all up for the top honor and as i
already mentioned he was nominated for
shy town that was the ultimate winner in
the best picture category that evening
and its super bowl shuffled its way home
with six wins i'm not even mad that's
amazing if you really want versatility
in the realm of cinema will ferrell
might be a surprising but accurate
choice however john c riley has proven
himself to be a master of so many
different types of roles the information
superhighway has coined the john c
reilly award it's unofficially given to
a performer who appears in the most best
picture nominees in any one year but my
boy john did it when there are only five
nomination slots it really is a lot of
fun
now it's what 10 movies and you and i
were probably in at least two of those
right we literally have never done any
of those things john c rowe is also
going to win this award
which is really just a point on my show
versus but hey that's a resume builder
now we got us a tied match once again at
two points a piece and it all comes down
to the next round checkmate
it's time for the wild card round
prestige worldwide
okay so here's how i arrived at this
decision i could have gone with the best
highlights over the years or which movie
from each competitor's resume is the
best and then pitted those flicks
against each other
but in my humble opinion and i haven't
had a carb since 2004
i think step brothers is the funniest
flick from will ferrell and john c riley
so why not make that the deciding round
it's all about that movie we're gonna
cherish it honor it and then maybe see
if one of the two step rows stands out
just a little bit more from the other
this is a house of learned doctors plus
it gives me a fresh excuse to go back
and watch stepbrother
no one in that entire cast is anything
less than exceptional mary steen virgin
as brennan that's will ferrell's
character's mom why are you guys so
sweaty richard jenkins as dale that's
john c rowley's role's dad adam scott is
brennan's brother catherine hahn as that
wife andrea savage as brennan's
therapist i love you
obviously
you don't know me i love you so much and
of course horatio sands as the lead
singer of uptown girl california's
pre-eminent 1980s billy joel cover band
we strictly do 80s joel music sir in
fact one of my favorite lines isn't from
feral or riley it's when a solid richard
jenkins utters at christmas
i'm gonna go to the cheesecake factory
have a drink
i really love this movie
dale is an emotional softy with a tough
exterior and some of his highlights
include wearing a tux with tails to a
job interview co-engineering bunk bed
carpentry that looks like you want you
would buy from a store and becoming the
head of a highly recommended catering
company he starts out as a shy dimwit
but comes into his own and eventually
realizes that he doesn't need a
chewbacca mask to pay the bills brennan
is too scared to show off his real
talent to the world so instead of
singing he resorts to hopping on dale's
drum set without dale's permission
hiring dale's company to work at the
catalina wine mixer
and eventually figuring out how to buy
basic household supplies at a store all
by himself
neither of the fellas have much luck
with the ladies brennan becomes obsessed
with the one female in his life that's
not his mom that would be his therapist
she's a rascal he harbors some fantasies
about what their lives could be together
but she's quick to bring him right back
down to earth throughout most of the
film in no way shape or form do i feel
any feelings of intimacy towards you in
any way whatsoever meanwhile with dale
it's not him who has the fantasies it's
katherine hans alice who so desperately
wants to leave her husband for dale it's
at this point when i need to remind
everyone that catherine hahn is a gem
and one of the funniest people who has
ever lived oh my god
you're incredible and that might be the
storyline that gets me leaning slightly
towards team dale when he punches derek
and derek falls out of the treehouse
it's the galvanizing force that allows
the two-step brothers to team up and
have all of these many misadventures
that was cool and it's also the inciting
action that starts alice's heated
obsession with human slash occasional
manatar dale brennan eventually feels so
comfortable with his new comrade that he
sings for him i think you took on the
shape of a unicorn yet it's dale that
comes up with the idea for prestige
worldwide why why why an
all-encompassing entertainment company
investors
possibly you and it's dale's dad's boat
at the boys commandeer to film their
mission statement music video what's
done is done dad are you guys going to
invest or not that's it
at the effin catalina wine mixer
all the stories and step brothers come
to a soaring climax those heights are
achieved largely thanks to the voice of
a generation brennan after uptown girl's
set gets ruined by a crowd desperate to
hear some 1970s tunes we only sing 80s
dogs but would we have heard that true
unicorn-like power of that generational
voice if dale hadn't first hopped on the
drums and saved the entire party it's as
tough of a call as i've had to make over
the many decades i've hosted verses but
i think i'm giving the edge in this
round to john c rowey's transcendental
performance as dale slightly over will
ferrell's incomparable brennan
you crazy man you sound insane do you
realize that now i might wake up
tomorrow and feel differently about this
decision but one thing will remain a
constant pound for pound line for a line
catherine hahn might be the one that
makes me laugh the hardest in this movie
come on let's try something illegal but
of our competitors today dale gets a nod
over brennan and john c riley wins the
round and thus the match you see your
actions have consequences so now that
i've made my ruling and it was against
comedy legend will ferrell i feel
compelled to point out that he's in one
of the funniest sketches in snl history
no not the cowbell one head to youtube
and search when will ferrell plays satan
after guest host garth brooks offers to
sell his soul to write a hit song it's
been lost amongst the era's greatest
sketches but should never be forgotten i
also throw in the fact that will ferrell
is an uber producer who makes a lot more
than just in the realm of comedy now
i'll put that against the fact that john
c reilly is steve bruhl and those make
the best gifts this side of a muppet
sipping tea
as for today's show in the as it always
seems to be here controversial outcome
remember it's just my opinion now it's
your turn go look at the entire
filmography of these two hilarious hunks
and hit me up on social media with your
favorite i'm at mark ellis live and
remember to check out the rotten movies
we love wherever books are sold justice
for step brothers thanks for watching
this episode of versus i'm mark ellis
and don't you ever touch my drum set
you